I do have to ask you since I have you
here last year you get you have you've
given us some teases about the winds of
winter but last year you dropped at the
bomb that you had a twist that you were
contemplating but you weren't sure if
you were going to go ahead with it can
you tell us if you've decided and if
we'll know what it is when we when we
eventually read it I have decided to do
that yes I have decided to do it and
will you know it I don't know it's
fairly obvious because it's uh something
involves a couple characters one of whom
is dead in the show but not dead in the
books so the show can't do this he is
you team because they've killed a
character that I have not killed but
that doesn't narrow it down much because
at this point they're like 15 characters
who are dead on the show we're still
alive in the books yeah I get one with
this the stuff about being bloody minded
I saw I saw your actors are expensive I
saw your office bathroom you have the
psycho bloody handprints I assume that's
where you take your characters did you
mention in the past that your friend
Phyllis gave you the note early on to
put the Dragons in do you think if you
hadn't gotten that note would you have
gone full fantasy would you have gone
full magic with a Song of Ice and Fire
um I don't I might have caught the same
conclusion anyway but but Phyllis
Eisenstein knows to write here I was
referring to did put our arguments
pretty forcefully I mean it always would
have been an alternate world a secondary
universe is toking called them you know
with not France and the Netherlands and
Spain but Westeros and Dorne and Essos
and Braavos and so on it was always
going to be that the question was should
be should the fantasy elements be overt
or should they be almost science-fiction
elements in disguise and that was the
other thing I was playing wet but there
would be people who commanded would seem
to be magical fire powers but maybe they
were just pyromancy psionic interesting
ability to you know to a classifier
your mind but I went with a literal
dragon because you know dragons are cool
and expensive to do one kill my but
worth it yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
yes I would so was the was the plan to
that the dragons existed and now or were
extinct as they kind of were and the in
the world and the said the note was to
actually bring them back alive in the
show or was that that know that that
Phyllis is known and this goes all the
way back to like 1991 or 92 but I don't
know long before was any two books were
written or published when I was debating
was whether the Dragons should exist at
all whether you know the Starks and
Wolf's on their banners rather people
have lions they don't necessarily have a
lion that they take with them everywhere
the Lannisters don't go writing about on
lions and the Targaryen s-- would have
the dragon but it would refer to their
magical abilities with fire not to a
actual literal trail and that was the
other concept that I toyed with him
ultimately discarded so I think that was
the right choice
we like the dragon yeah we like okay
with the Dragons expensive or not now
what's interesting with serialized
storytelling like this is you know you
go in and you know you're getting a full
story you you know at some point there's
going to have a beginning middle and end
regardless of how long it goes some
curious for you guys with these barriers
serialized style Ettore storytelling do
you know the ending when you start and
at what point do you know now is the
time to end it which I know is a bit
pre-emptive for you because this is
season one right yeah but I'm just
curious George has had a little more
time so I'll defer to him first
I know the ending in broad strokes but
broad strokes are just broad strokes and
the devil is in the details
so as I as I write these last two books
I'll be moving toward the endings that
I've known since 1991 but many in the
fine details may be moved around and
and changed and things like that of
course I'm writing books I mean although
it's a successful TV series you know
David Benioff and Dan Weiss er are doing
that and have somewhat different
challenges that the problem and Brian
and I were actually talking about this a
little bit dinner before that with uh
with doing a serialized television show
is unfortunately television shows can be
canceled at any moment or can be
unexpectedly renewed at any moment and
which makes it hell for the the writer
producer trying to you know resolve this
I mean you look at sure like st.
elsewhere which ended perfectly
satisfactorily with with the hospital
having gone bankrupt and a wrecking ball
comes down and smashes in the front of
the the st. Eligius Hospital but we've
been following for so many seasons and
of show great end of show and then the
network says oh no we want you back for
another season so they quickly have to
write another season where after the
closing Bowl someone comes running in
and saying no no I have my spell orders
stop there for those season and then
they don't get renewed and they have to
come up with the ending where the entire
show was actually the dream of an
autistic boy gazing into a snow globe I
found so what you're telling us as we
really hope that gap HBO doesn't pull
that bait and switch with Game of
Thrones
[Laughter]
yeah I mean you know the the advantage
that Carlton and I have had is all the
colonies a very news show we've been
talking about it for two and a half
years and we spent a lot of time at the
very beginning before we ever talked
about the actual what the pilot story
was or anything like that we talked
about the world and what the story was
and this the Bowman family at the center
of it and where they go and what the
evolutions are from season to season
throughout we can do a season about this
and we can do a season about that so we
actually have a very clear picture in
mind of what the ending of the show is
what the last season of the show is I
but what I don't yet know is all of the
material from from A to F you know and
maybe not a full size G instead of you
know more aspirational but um then I
think that's the the trick of
storytelling is that you want to have a
destination to write to but I think the
material that you you discover and let
find you along the way it's important to
let the creative process happen so
that's a bit fluid but yes we we know
where we want to end the story so what
is your favorite sci-fi or fantasy story
that is not your own book any probably
book I would lean towards book
personally um nine purchase and amber
were registered lasting or possibly Lord
of Light by Roger Zelazny
I'm adding it to my George our Martin
Oprah's reading list as we sit here well
maybe the stars my destination by Alfred
Bester there's a lot of great ones out
there that could be filmed nine princess
and amber would make an incredible TV
series it's it's you know very games of
throne esque but with a flavor that's
you know uniquely its own and you know
nine Prince's competing for a single
throne that's not even counting their
sisters the most devious of all here
handed and a series of alternate
universes and you can walk from one to
the other if you're at the blood of
amber it's Roger Zelazny lived in San
and he was one of the great great
writers of this genre but for you I'm
gonna go with the pandering seemingly
pandering response but for me it's a
song of ice and fire I mean it was a
huge influence on me when I was when I
was coming off his writer and I got into
the book series long before the TV show
I read them for Asia Slee again and
again and it really was a big influence
I mean kind of early on as I was trying
to start writing on my own and I still
revisit them every couple of years I
can't well so George you've you've
worked in TV before people can't see
this here but there is there a whole
bunch of Beauty and the Beast posters in
the room next to us which I get such a
kick out of but you were like the pace
isn't for you the way that it worked at
least at the time was not for you so I'm
curious I haven't seen you write a novel
or talked about that at all do you have
any interest in going to the other side
like George - I think so yes but I think
I think I'm I'm looking to that as kind
of being the the thing that I want to do
after you know I I'm really excited by
what TV is and can be today and I think
there were a lot of interesting things
that happened in the last couple of
years you know it's spurred on by shows
like Game of Thrones are really broken
the mold in a lot of ways and I think
there's a lot of interesting stuff left
to be done and but I do I do a vision a
day of log cabins and tweed jackets with
elbow patches exactly exactly this is a
golden age for science fiction
television in television there's never
been so many shows on before and it's
it's partly a consequence of the fact
that special effects are so much more
advanced with computer animation and
things like that we can do things that
we could not have dreamed of when I was
doing MIDI and the Beast and The
Twilight Zone before that but it's also
a function of the fact that we have so
many outlets now dividing up the
audience I mean in when I first came on
Twilight Zone in the in the mid 80s
there were three networks and that was
the only place you could you could do a
drama you know
independent stations and the syndication
they gives reran a little network stuff
and they had a few local those little
clown shows and all that but you needed
a masked general audience and science
fiction is a specialized audience that
doesn't there's just a lot of people
just don't get it and that's true or
fantasy too but now that we're not
slicing the pie into three huge slices
that you can be successful with just a
thin slice of the pie there's enough pie
for a hundred shows and we're seeing
them and some are great and some are
less great but it's it's great to see
all this creativity happening well and
that's why we have the benefit of
networks like USA getting really into
the Syfy game